une crise sanitaire qui a aussi durement
au bouleversé la vie des étudiants
oui aujourd'hui syndicats et
organisations de la jeunesse appelle les
étudiants à se mobiliser à des
mobilisations sont prévues partout en
france à paris les étudiants sont
attendus devant la sorbonne où on va
retrouver tout de suite notre reporter
et celle farges
[Musique]
bonjour estelle les étudiants donc qui
veulent se faire entendre aujourd'hui
des étudiants qui sont dans une
situation de détresse il s'exprime
également sur les réseaux sociaux ces
étudiants exactement magali hashtag
étudiants fantômes depuis quelques jours
ce mot clé est très présent sur les
réseaux sociaux ils témoignent tout
simplement de la détresse des étudiants
face à la crise sanitaire un des
étudiants qui se sentent elles laissées
pour compte et il compte bien se faire
entendre aujourd'hui puisque vous l'avez
dit plusieurs mobilisations sont prévues
dans tout le pays pour défendre je cite
les conditions de vie et d'études des
étudiants alors plus précisément ils
demandent la réouverture des universités
pour tous je vous propose d'écouter est
la présidence la présidente de l'unef
union nationale des étudiants de france
nous ce qu'on demande c'est qu'on
dédoubler les classes on peut étaler les
cours sur les journées partir sur du
50-50 de l'hybridation est dédoublé les
amphis les td et c'est pour qu'on puisse
ca des cours dans des conditions
sanitaires acceptables et avec mes moins
de brassage possible alors ici à paris à
la manifestation est prévue à 14 heures
au départ de port royal et elle prendra
la direction du ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur
estelle du côté des annonces du
gouvernement où est ce qu'on enlève
et bien lors de sa conférence de presse
la semaine dernière le premier ministre
jean castex a annoncé que les étudiants
en première année à l'université
pourrait reprendre les td les travaux
est dirigé en présentiel et en demi
groupe à partir du 25 janvier mais
globalement aucune date n'a encore été
avancée pour la reprise totale des cours
le gouvernement à qui ce dit préoccupés
par l'isolément ou du moins ce sentiment
d'isolement de la part des étudiants
jean castex a par ailleurs annoncé que
80 à psychologue et 60 assistants
sociaux seraient mobilisés en renfort
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2021 les
consultations chez un psychologue
pourrait aussi être financés pour les
étudiants en difficulté via un
dispositif de chèque de soutien
psychologique
réponse de l'unef on a l'impression que
le gouvernement ne prend pas la mesure
de la situation fin de citation l'unef
qui réclament aussi une hausse des
bourses et des aides au logement
merci beaucoup et se télécharge arrêt
estelle qui va suivre en direct
justement ces manifestations qui sont
prévues partout en france
manifestation des étudiants français
aujourd'hui